And of course when the child is old enough
to be put into the great social world,
then all restrictions related to the playing ground become
placed immediately on the child.
And that is a very unforgivable landscape, because
the last thing a child wants, really, the last
what a child wants is not to have friends.
Or even, maybe, just as seriously,
don't have a best friend.
Ah, I recently read something so idiotic that I couldn't believe it, so
the newest prince,
so Queen Elisabeth's great-grandchild,
is in childcare in England.
And in this daycare they don't let the children have a best friend,
because that is unfair. I thought, you know
sometimes you see something that is so stupid
that you can't even believe it really exists.
And this is an example of that,
because it has long been known that
one of the milestones in the development
those children undergo, somewhere between the age
5 and 10 is that they choose a best friend.
* stuttering *
The hypothesis 'but that is unfair for all other children',
Look, first of all you can't be everyone's best friend.
Because then
maybe there are 1 billion children, so every child gets 1 second.
And that is not a very deep relationship. So,
the idea that you can be just as good with everyone,
that is impossible. But even worse, the thing is,
The thing the child does is actually them
they step out of their own self-centeredness,
because their best friend becomes more important than they are.
And that is a precursor to an adult relationship
in which, if you are married, your partner
at least as important as you and the relationship should be
should be even more important. But then you have children
and they are more important than you are. That's a fact.
Unless there is something wrong with you. You come second
and your children come first.
And then very first, I mean * stutter *
you are important because without you they can't do anything, so
you have to take care of yourself. You are no longer first when you have children.
Unless, seriously, you haven't learned the lessons from the playground.
And when you have a best friend you are not first, but they are.
And thus..
But anyway there are these limitations that develop
in the social landscape. You must have friends,
and you also need a specific person like
particularly unique among these friends,
giving you a real, mutual and caring relationship.
I can't remember the psychiatrist who studied this so carefully.
Uhm, unfortunately.
He was the first person who detailed
did analyzes of the 'best friends' relationships
that children create. It is, I want
gladly give him honor for his ideas, but unfortunately
I can't remember his name. So,
All right!